[Music]
so no one outside of her own
neighborhood had ever heard of kamala
harris before she showed up as willie
brown's girlfriend then a few years
later she became monte williams's
girlfriend interesting long before she
met doug emhoff she dated some prominent
men including in 2001 former talk show
host montel williams back then he was
the famous one and had to introduce her
to the paparazzi
it's interesting that that tape never
played anywhere before the election and
it probably would have made a difference
but it would have been nice to know
anyway as you know kamala harris somehow
went on to become a senator and then the
vice president of the united states now
she accomplished all of that without
really any support from actual voters we
know that because there's a lot of
polling on it virtually no one in
california her home state for example
supported her presidential campaign and
now currently she's an approval rating
of 28 percent
right around jeffrey dahmer's approval
rating
why
i don't know moments like this
she would tell the story about houston
they're marching
and this is back when strollers didn't
really have arm rest and seat belts
so they're marching away and you know
shouting and and all of that and then i
think it was my uncle freddie you know
looked down and looked in the stroller
which was empty
and said
where's on
and apparently it left me like a block
behind i'd fallen out the stream
there you go and then my mother would
tell a funny story about how like one
day she did and i was fussing and you
know and so i'm fussing and fuss and she
it's much cuter when she would tell the
story but she'd say so then she would
look down at me and come look what do
you want what do you want and i looked
back up and i said freedom
it's just fascinating watching that how
transparently false it is it's like
everyone went along with what everyone
could tell was a lie it's interesting so
larry elder is from california in fact
he just ran for governor of california
we strongly supported him in that he's a
radio host there he joins us tonight to
assess kamala harris larry elder great
to see you thank you
thank you thank you for having me you've
watched kamala harris for years
what do you make of this right it's
baffling to me
well it is baffling because if you look
at it on paper tucker she's a pretty
successful politician she ran for and
got elected attorney general in
california beating out her competition
she ran for and got elected senator uh
beating out her competition and then she
had this disaster run as vice president
and as you pointed out even people in
california didn't support her you know
the key to being a successful politician
having been one for eight weeks a couple
of things uh in his authenticity
and likability
and she has neither
and part of it is because
you look at things like her record as
a.g she was known as a soft on crime
part of me hard on crime ag and then she
got kind of busted during the debate
with uh tulsi gabbard when she pointed
out that she prosecuted marijuana
offenders not not not
possession but but offenders dealers and
then joked about marijuana on a radio
program
she also
uh brag that she was uh the last person
in the room when joe biden made the
decision to uh pull out of afghanistan
which means she parted that decision and
the only reason in my my opinion she
became vice president is because she
checked all the boxes the democrats in
this woke era are no longer going to
have two white males on the ticket it's
got to be at least a person of color uh
hopefully a person of color who's a
female so she's checked all the boxes
and and has proven herself to be
basically utterly incompetent they're
now backbiting she'd even accused or at
least one of her staffers accused joe
biden of being racist so she's not
unwilling to pull the race card in order
to defend herself and that's offended a
lot of people you you played her laugh
she has this cackle
that a lot of people just find
off-putting when she gets into a tough
position when she doesn't have an answer
for something when somebody corners her
she she refers to this silly laughter
and it off and it just angers people and
talking if i can say one more thing
it's not fixed in stone the good news
for her is that 2024 uh is a mile away
uh and as you know that's a that's a
that's an eternity in politics and you
can change that ronald reagan was
perceived by all of us who knew him as a
sunny optimistic guy but a lot of
democrats didn't feel that way until he
was shot and here he is the most anger
he could summon against his would-be
assassin was what's that guy's beef and
as he being wheeling to the operating
room he tells the doctors i hope you
guys are all republicans and he told
nancy nancy reagan i forgot to duck and
people said wow he really is genuine he
really is likable so it's possible to
change it but given colin harris's
numbers given her track record given
this laugh given the way she's run away
from her record as being tough on crime
she had the most left-wing voting record
more left-wing than bernie sanders and
now and then position herself as a
centrist sometimes she says she's a
black woman when she ran sometimes she
said she's an asian indian woman when
she ran out here in california so she's
perceived to be utterly inauthentic and
utterly unlikable yeah i'd rather have
i'd rather have willie brown any day and
i don't agree with willie brown but at
least he's a real person no i did very
nicely mary elder thank you good to see
you tonight